et donc c'est difficile pour vous de
faire des trucs comme avant sur
n'importe quoi puisque maintenant tout
le monde vous connaissez on va les
nombreux à se susurrait d'aller chez le
médecin se faire soigner une mycose par
exemple toi c'est tout de suite là ou
quoi
et le bar on va en aie aie aie alors on
va faire une interview
si personne ne sait si personne ne le
sait pas ce que c'est qu'un seul essai
assez croustillant jackson le c est ce
que tu pourrais trompeta pas si personne
ne sait à ces personnes nous sommes même
pas elle ouais c'est dur ça comme truc
parce que tu es obligé de répondre non
si personne ne sait quoi mais qui est
vrai mais personne un moment donné ça
c'est énorme mais si tu as toujours un
mec qui va à un moment du repas alors et
d'olivier si personne ne sait si
vraiment emerson laisser un bas j'ai
envie de dire oui ou pas sur ça peut
arriver et si personne ne sait qui
pourrait les voir une call-girl olivier
six personnes le seui et personne ne
sait quoi sur confiance et kouassi n'da
là qu'on appelle ici personne ne sait
s'il faut refaire bulls et laurent gerra
sur un scénario de film si personne ne
sait non valable le coup non parce que
non non non je crois pas bon non l'avant
parce que non même si personne ne sait
quand je vois tout le monde le sache que
j'ai passé
si personne ne sait qui l'anniversaire
je ne fais même si personne ne sait ce
que vous pourriez vous mettre
sérieusement sur la gueule on ce qu'on
se bat qu'on s'engueule comme un conte
se pousse pousse la sauver ouais c'est
pas ça parce que la région dont le
savoir ouais voilà
mais non ça paraisse voir si personne
mais c est ce que vous pourriez faire
une pub pour une lotion anti chute au
japon ok ouais non je vois la légion ok
personne
moi j'aimerais bien mais ce que je
trouve ça super classement et quand je
vois jean reno tous âges unis pts a
quand même qu après il arrive au japon
le theux ces tapis rouge
et ça aussi la réserve il a fait la
bière ou du whisky et bien sûr c'est
l'axé lost in translation et c'est pour
ça c'est magnifique voilà mais
maintenant ça va être
après les choristes on m'a déjà proposé
à une pub pour un sexy 6-2 au pakistan
ces personnes le sérieux tu pourrais
être riche et sur tes impôts toi si
personne ne sait tricher sur les impôts
acheteurs ont fait tous un petit peu on
a 10% de d'erreur de marge d'erreur moi
les 10% ils sont directs voilà je fais
ça fait 1 millions d'euros d'économisés
six personnes le ckd ouais tu pourrais
taper un gosse taper un gosse a tapé
physique mouais si personne ne sait à
six personnes
si personne ne le sait mais tu pourrais
tourner dans un porno
ah ouais ouais ça sera que si personne
ne sait vous pourriez avoir une aventure
tous les deux tiers que je vais je y
pénètre par exemple qui me plais trouver
pourquoi je ne te paie les forêts pas
parce que tu sais très bien pourquoi
kaleo la belle
kad et o monro jaquette